Turning Point USA is pledging $10,000 to
the legal fund of Michael Cassidy
Christian veteran who beheaded s satanic
Idol in Iowa state capital well I'm
going to ask Luke what he thinks first
because he's the he's the anarchist over
here yeah same thing is it confirmed
satanic listen there's a lot of demon
worshippers inside of the government
that's a fact now do you have freedom of
of religion do you have freedom of of
speech and expression I think so as well
and I think we we have to understand
that there's a delicate kind of uh line
that we have to go down here as of
course we still got to respect people's
individuals Liberty uh but let's call
out the Satanist as well um you don't
have to resort to to BLM tactics in
order to kind of express your opinion
was it actually satanic or
was it has BFF and the tenants of
Satanism and all that stuff and uh you
know I I am not a fan of Satanism I am
not ignorant to Satanism I've read their
tenants I understand what they're saying
I not a fan of it